GILBERT STRANG:
Well, I'm Gil Strang.
And I'm very happy if you
know the linear algebra
videos on OpenCourseWare
or on YouTube.
That's for the
math course 18.06.
And I'm even happier
if you like them.
And I'm here today to update
them for several reasons.
Well, a lots happened in
linear algebra in these years.
Fortunately, the
whole subject has just
become more and more essential,
more and more important, more
and more beautiful.
And so I wanted to say something
about those later steps.
And also, when I teach it now,
I have a new starting point.
And I'll show you that.
So I'll go a little slowly
on that starting point.
The slides tell you
the whole course.
And that's crazy to have a full
course within a short video.
But especially the
first part is new.
And I'm even writing
a textbook called
Linear Algebra for Everyone
that will start this way.
I hope that the new start brings
in real linear algebra ideas
right away.
And let me show you
where those are.
So this is an outline
of the whole video.
And the first
line, which I think
about in my mind as
matrix A, is a product
of a C matrix, a column
matrix, and a row matrix R.
And you'll see what those are.
So that's the new idea.
That will come first.
Then these are five
famous essential shorthand
descriptions of the key
chapters of linear algebra,
the key chapters.
So they represent, for example,
LU is those letters are famous.
And computer commands
would be exactly
those letters LU for elimination
for solving equations,
the first job of linear algebra.
And then QR.
So Q is a very interesting
important type of matrix.
That's standing for
an orthogonal matrix.
There is the word
orthogonal or perpendicular.
So those are the best
matrices to compute with.
And that QR gets us there.
And S is for a symmetric matrix.
And it will involve--
oh, well, I should
say, the first half,
ending with there, with QR,
is about solving equations.
The second half, these
three are about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
and singular values,
a different way to approach the
whole subject and a very, very
important way.
Among my goals is to help
courses around the world
get singular values
included because you really
don't want to miss them.
That's the high
point of the theory.
And it's expressed
like all the others
as breaking a matrix into
two or three pieces, two
or three parts.
So that's my plan
for this video.
And I hope it's helpful.
Again, it's a whole
course in a short time.
And please go to the real
18.06 videos for the details.
Thanks